[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's bring in the hall of famer jim
nance jim was on the call steelers and
the packers he has the dolphins and the
buccaneers this sunday on cbs morning
jim how are you
hello friend i like this little chat
you're having about best quarterbacks
under the age of 24. it's uh it's an
exciting time for the game and i mean
you could pretty much draw any one of
those names and be happy but this kid
justin herbert is amazing we saw it
again last night i had two of the first
three games
and he's not only the real real deal but
this team is they're going to be in it
to the end i think
all right on the other side of that
rainbow you have ben roethlisberger you
got you and tony got to see ben up close
personal uh what would you do if you're
mike tomlin in the steelers with ben
uh
that's a tough one because i
you know he truly truly doesn't have any
help up front there is absolutely no
cohesion when you go looking at left
tackle we're not talking about a first
round we're talking about a fourth
rounder at left tackle a second year
player at left guard who didn't play a
ton last year in a rookie center
what do you expect
i mean in in the game that we saw
he threw a strike down the field on
their first possession to deontay
johnson that looked like the bend of old
but i mean he's running for his life the
problem is he can't run like he used to
remember how hard he was to bring down
you couldn't ever tackle well that's
different now but uh i would give it
some more time i think there's uh
way too much pressure right now and
attention on gotta make a change by the
way if they had a quarterback and
waiting that i thought was gonna have a
better outcome that would be another
story i don't see that right now so uh
i i'm still with ben and uh and i think
it's a sign of respect too i mean
he's a hall of famer i mean big time
career records and all that and uh
you don't want to see anybody in their
career that way where people are dumping
on you but also jim you know how this
works everybody has to have a take we
every week it's like that's i know
exactly how good that team is or how bad
that team is i mean jameis winston was a
dark horse candidate for mvp after week
one aaron rodgers didn't care about
playing for the packers he's nonchalant
like you and tony probably have to fight
that urge of saying i kind of
know what this team is or this this
player is
i'm not a hot take guy dan and i know we
live in a hot take world and i was
watching the pregame shows on sunday i
won't name any names but
you know i heard someone would make a
declaration that you can take it to the
bank that the giants are going to be 0
and 10 after 10 weeks if you look at
their schedule you can book it right now
they're 010. three hours later they've
got a victory so it's just
hey that was a great take
the pro the problem is it had a very
short shelf life and
sometimes you have to just kind of weed
through all this and try to get to
something that's a little more common
sense
how are your conversations with aaron
rodgers
you'd be uh i don't think you'd be
surprised because you've talked to him
enough times the guy is brilliant
and uh he's he's thoughtful he's
insightful we we talked to him on friday
and i asked him who was uh harder to
replace i never got this on the air by
the way so now i got a place to dispense
this information this is great who was
harder to replace brett favre or alex
trebek
okay
what do you think
alex trebek
bingo
correct
because he can do what brett favre did
it's really hard to replicate what alex
trebek did and trebek did it for over
three decades
you know he's an interesting study
uh
aaron because when his career is over
and he's he's nowhere close i believe to
call it a quits i think that longevity
wise
if there's a guy that's going to do it
as long as tom brady is going to set the
pace here i i think aaron's the guy that
could do it
now where will he be that's another
question but after football his next act
he could be a game show host i know that
he's interested in doing that and it
doesn't have to be jeopardy it could be
something else i think he could be
enacting
uh we we know that in his personal life
he's close to that hollywood world uh
hollywood world and if you watch his
commercials he's pretty darn gifted at
it if he wanted to be an analyst
and sit in the booth
i think he would be exceptional so i
mean he's got
so many options out there
uh it's going to be an interesting study
but i think that's five or six years
down the road minimum were you
approached
to audition for uh jeopardy
no
no and and uh i had a lot of people ask
me that not
i'm not talking about in the media but i
got asked that by friends i had no
interest in i don't wanna ever cloud
this is just me okay that doesn't mean
anybody else you know if they wanted to
do it and have some fun with it that's
cool but my love is is is telling
stories about sports i don't aspire to
be anything else
uh i kind of like
dabbled in that world a little bit early
in my career i hosted the the morning
show on cbs as a fill-in as a backup to
brian gumbel and eventually i got
offered that job full-time and i faced a
real crossroads of my career did i want
to go in the news or did i want to stay
with what was driving me what was in my
heart since i was a kid
and
once i made that decision i wasn't going
to news i wasn't going the morning
television i was staying in sports i
made the determination then i don't want
to ever cloud the picture again this
just is for me by the way
i think it takes a lot of talent to be
able to do that i know there are others
who audition i know joe did it he did it
well but for me i just want people to
know that i love what i'm doing that
doesn't mean everybody else doesn't love
what they're doing but i don't want to
be doing anything else this is the job
of my dreams and i cherish it and that's
just the way i look at
there's a new book out uh you are
looking live that's the opening line of
the uh new show that uh was on cbs in
1975. the nfl today and it launched the
careers of brent mossberger phyllis
george irv cross jimmy the greek and uh
the title of the book uh
you know uh you wrote jim you wrote the
uh
the forward to this
what did that what did that show mean to
you
when you were growing up
that was my favorite show on television
now people would say wait a minute you
can't count that against episodic
television like mission impossible and
all in the family and mary tyler moore
but for me i couldn't wait until 12 30
on sundays people forget it was a half
hour show dan you know it it wasn't an
hour show you didn't have programming
all week long you didn't have the
content you didn't have the internet you
didn't have the feedback we were all
starved for information those of us who
loved the nfl and that show not only
provided you that information it
entertained you so
uh it it really truly was one of the
things that tugged me to want to be in
this business rich
did a fabulous job writing this book and
as far as history in the industry you
won't believe some of the things that
are in there that extend beyond the base
crew that you just talked about
i was blown away by his research
and how close he was to so many of those
people for example it gets into some of
the history of people that came through
cbs back in the 70s not just in the
studio i'll take al michaels okay i
mentioned now on the broadcast on sunday
al happened on sunday to have the game
of the year that everyone wanted
tampa bay and new england it fell the
date october the 3rd on the exact
year to the day anniversary
of al's first ever nfl call which was
buffalo against minnesota on nbc johnny
morris
was his broadcast partner
and
not only was oj in the game al cowlings
played in the game for buffalo norm
snead was a quarterback for minnesota
howe got 750 to do that game now rich
got into the fact that that was that was
al's
first game then he came over to cbs to
do play-by-play for a short while but
i called out on friday
i had somebody tipped me off on the date
and everything that was going to be that
day he did not know
he's are you sure i said you can look it
up october the 3rd and i said i'm going
to mention on on on sunday in the double
header game pal but
yeah there's just some great background
you are looking live
that those words when they would leave
the lips of brent mussberger who i just
have endless respect for brent uh they
would give me chills you know we're so
similar dan and age and likes and
dislikes i know it impacted you the same
way i know you felt the same extensive
excitement when the first shot would
come up out of black and you are looking
live at rfk stadium in washington and
you just you were just totally riveted
and
i this book comes at a really really
good time i believe because you don't
get too far past those glory days that
was in my estimation the greatest studio
show of all time and somebody needed to
document it and nobody could have done
it better than rich did and then you
find out that brent would say you're
looking live to let the gamblers know
these are the weather conditions at
soldier field
you know when i auditioned for cbs in
1985
i i auditioned on a saturday early in
the football season
um
and and uh i won the host role for
college
college football and and and hosted the
show with pat hayden a few weeks later
teddy shaker who is our executive
producer had a huge impact on me getting
my career started he said you want to
come by and watch brent do the show well
he didn't have to ask twice so i stuck
around after one of my early shows on
cbs and i sat in the back of the studio
and i watched him do the greek's corner
and i watched him come on that wide shot
with that great ant of the song
behind the nfl
just i'm like is this real did i
actually sit in that same chair
yesterday this is crazy is this really
happening um
the show was mesmerizing phyllis of
course
was pioneering and groundbreaking we
just lost her sadly we also just lost
her cross mike pearl who was the
producer behind that show
died in this last year um
but true legendary stuff and i think
anyone who's a sports fan is gonna love
love this book whether you're old enough
to remember that show or not
do you ever gamble
uh if you call fantasy football gambling
i guess um but not on the game
oh gosh no no
no i don't even know and i need to
probably pay a little more attention to
it because you know you see where
everybody's going with it yeah it's just
it's everywhere the commercials you go
to it's it's all talking we're first off
that is absolutely taboo if you're if
you're calling games and and gambling at
the same time now i'm not saying the
likelihood that there are people out
there doing it in our profession is very
high i would never think about doing
that um i just i it's just it's just
ethically i don't think you can do it
but
um are you factoring in point spreads
though in
you know during your broadcast
is it mentioned
i don't i probably should pay
closer attention to it uh take al for
example he's always had fun
with this game isn't over
yeah
i haven't worked those in because i feel
like that's kind of the al's
got the rights to that um
but i did pittsburgh and green bay on on
sunday i couldn't tell you right now
what the line was for that game so
i'm so locked into the process of
preparation talking to players and
coaches you get a pretty good feel after
you meet with everyone where the game
might be going oftentimes you're
surprised but the lines i don't pay any
attention to
uh seton o'connor of course one of the
danettes does some impersonations that
uh you might be uh entertained by seton
do you want to give jim nance your al
michael's impersonation and not many
people do an al michael's impersonation
but
seton did this to al michaels just to
let you know all right and there he goes
the lamar jackson game he kept saying
and there he goes
and so
seton goes five wide empty backfield and
there he goes
and if we had tony romo on seton also
does a tony romo impersonation he's
going to run it jim we're going to run
to the left there you go
seton you know i
of course you know we've been in each
other's company before and i didn't know
you had the talent that could go this
far wide uh it's just becoming
caliendo s wow wow
yeah he's getting good you know he's got
he's got a bit that he does with uh with
our booth and he and he does tony i
think he's got tony just dead ringer
that he has me always no matter what the
scenario is saying tony
[Laughter]
there was a time when frank first came
out with that i admire him greatly by
the way um one of the first times he he
came out with that bit and i was having
everyone afford it to me like have you
seen this have you seen it yeah i've
seen it and i continue to see it
and um
i said to tony i said we got to work
this into the game
so we did we had i can't tell you the
game was late last season and it might
maybe even reappear on a national
network double header game coming to you
soon but whatever we go through um
if there's a big play and it merits it
we do a little if you will spoof of
frank doing us
tony
tony
i didn't realize he did that but it
works for me yeah hey it's great to see
you uh hope you're doing well and uh
have fun with the dolphins in the
buccaneers this sunday
thanks pal let's stay in touch thank you
talk to you that's jim nance hall of
famer and the uh he wrote the forward to
the book you are looking live